Quizfrage was ist grün und stinkt in den
Umfragen ab richtig die Grünen war zu
einfach war viel zu einfach ja woran
liegt es liegt an handwerklichen Fehlern
an schlechter Kommunikation aber auch
daran dass die Grünen den Bürgern mit
konkreten Klimaschutzmaßnahmen weiter
auf den Sack gehen ne besser so konkret
ach Klimaschutz doch nie gedacht wir
fahren das als Konzept gut ja klar
plötzlich ist Robert Habeck also der
Boomer in seiner Rolle als nerviger
wärmepumpenvertreter ja das ist jetzt
die Realität allein das Wort Wärmepumpe
regt viele auf mein Name ist Fabian
[Applaus]
und ich sag jetzt schon mal obwohl es
noch nicht soweit ist ich lasse mir auch
keine Wärmepumpe einbauen
interessiert keine Sau mach doch was du
willst
sie denn Bill Gates will uns allen
heimlich Wärmepumpen einpflanzen wussten
sie das geht schon wieder los habex
Gebäude Energiegesetz erhitzt die
deutschen Gemüter vor allem jetzt wo der
deutsche Heizungshersteller Viessmann
sich beim Amerikaner prostituiert ja
seitdem seit dem Jaulen alle rum
Ausverkauf einer Zukunftstechnologie
dabei haben Viessmann Bosch und wie sie
alle heißen viel zu lange für Gasheizung
lobbyiert und wundern sich heute das
anders so konkurrenzfähiger und
günstiger Wärmepumpen gebaut werden wir
haben das Thema verpennt wir haben es
insgesamt verpennt und sind erst
aufgewacht als Putin die Ukraine
überfallen hat ja Deutschland von Putin
unschuldig zum Klimaschutz gezwungen das
sind die Tatsachen ja
es ist doch so ja ja übrigens wer sich
schon vor Jahren eine Wärmepumpe gekauft
hat in Deutschland war der Exot der
Straße
gesagt was ist das für Unsinn warum
nimmst du keine gastheizung noch das ist
ja kompletter Schwachsinn und mit den
Gaspreiserhöhungen war das dann auf
einmal
ja
der Mann geht zum Lachen in den Keller
weil da seine Wärmepumpe steht in
Dänemark sind Öl und Gasheizungen in
Neubauten schon seit 2013 verboten also
seit zehn Jahren in Norwegen wird
fossile Energie mit bis zu 78% besteuert
da heizen 60% der Privathaushalte mit
Wärmepumpe meine Wärmepumpe ist ja jetzt
auch keine Raketentechnologie ganz
ehrlich das kann wirklich jeder einbauen
der Kanzler selbst schraubte bei
Viessmann vergangenen Sommer an einer
Wärmepumpe
also die Pumpe ist jetzt natürlich
kaputt logisch
er hat versucht
decarbonisierung findet längst weltweit
statt und die Märkte der Zukunft werden
jetzt gerade aufgeteilt wer den Bürgern
irgendwas anderes einredet gefährdet
unseren Wohlstand womit wir nahtlos bei
Christian Lindner werden ja der Fossil
wäre hier
schwadoniert weiter von Gasheizung die
Wasserstoff ready sind vor allem wären
die wenn sie denn eines Tages immer
kommen Arsch teuer und ineffizient was
man allerdings wiederum habe ich
vorwerfen muss keiner blickt mehr durch
in Sachen staatliche Förderung und
Ausnahmen bei der Wärmepumpe alles schon
wieder viel zu kompliziert
Barbies Traumhaus zu 65 Prozent mit
regenerativen beheizt so wie ist das
neue Gebäude Energiegesetz vorschreibt
es sei denn du bist über 80 aber das
musst du beim
Bezirksschornsteinfeger nachweisen hol
dir jetzt Barbies Traumhaus mit
Wärmepumpe und gratis dazu 172 Seiten
mit allen original Ausnahmeregeln bist
du die kapiert hast bist du wirklich
über 80
Barbies bürokratisches albtraumhaus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das muss doch einfacher gehen warum
gibt's da noch keine Klarheit man könnte
sagen es läuft also nur so Mittel bei
der wärmewende und es sind insgesamt
schwere Zeiten für Robert habe Weg denn
on top ist da ja auch noch der Vorwurf
der Vetternwirtschaft im
Wirtschaftsministerium
Opposition und Medien schäumen aber was
ist da dran fragen wir direkt mal nach
bei Christian Ehring er leitet inhabetes
Haus die neu gegründete Task Force
friends and family die alle
Verpflichtungen offenlegen soll Hering
wie läuft's heute schon irgendeine
Cousine eingestellt
ja sehr witzig Herr welke kille kille
ich Sorge hier ab sofort für maximale
Transparenz meine erfahrenste
Sachbearbeiterin geht noch mal sämtliche
Personalakten durch ja es sind Fehler
passiert aber was hier abgeht in diesem
Land ist doch ein Stellvertreterkrieg
die Grünen an sich sollen fertig gemacht
werden und jedes Wort das mein Chef
jemals gesagt hat wird ihm im Munde
umgedreht ein Vorteil ist ja mal so ein
bisschen die Grünen sind die Oberlehrer
und wollen uns erzählen wie wir unser
Leben leben sollen was sagen sie dazu
nein bestimmt nicht wir wissen es
einfach besser
und ich sag noch bitte versuch nicht
witzig zu sein Robert aber das ist ja
gar nicht der Punkt was sind denn
überhaupt die konkreten Vorwürfe gegen
uns da müsste man jetzt eigentlich mal
so eine stinklangweilige erklärtafel
reinrollen wie in der Anstalt wo die
Zuschauer direkt der Angstschweiß
rausbringen kann aber irgendjemand ah ja
ja danke schön Klaus
nicht mit mir verwandt übrigens so ist
ja im Prinzip auch ganz einfach hier
oben haben wir den Big Boss den großen
Käse unseren Robert Chef von Patrick
reichen Staatssekretär dann gibt es das
Öko-Institut das von unserem Haus
Aufträge kriegt und da arbeiten wiederum
Jakob reichen und Verena reichen Bruder
und Schwester von
Patrick reichen ah deshalb heißen die
alle Grenchen ja aber sag mal was ist
denn mit den Staatssekretär da ganz
unten diesem Kellner der heißt ja gar
nicht reichen ja sieht aus wie ein
Fehler ich weiß kann man aber erklären
das ist der Ehemann von Verena greifen
im übrigen Arbeiten im Öko-Institut
natürlich auch noch ganz viele Leute die
nicht zur gleichen Familie gehören wie
der Hausmeister
egal aber da sind viele so und zu all
dem ist jetzt leider noch eine ganz
blöde Sache dazu gekommen der patrick
hat wohl versehentlich dem Michael
Schäfer seinem eigenen Trauzeugen den
chefbosten in der Deutschen
Energieagentur gegeben
seinem trauzeug wie jetzt versehentlich
ja Patrick sagt wirklich im Verfahren
der Findungskommission habe ich leider
nicht richtig aufgepasst
das heißt dieser Bewerber und er dachte
noch irgendwo her kenn ich den Vogel
woher kenne ich den denn nur
Familienfeier Saunaclub man kommt nicht
drauf mein gott ist uns doch allen schon
passiert ja mir nicht aber der Patrick
bleibt trotzdem im Amt ja
selbstverständlich warum denn auch nicht
scheiß doch immer die Familie ist die
Keimzelle der Gesellschaft und hier wird
das eben noch gelebt im Familien im
Wirtschaftsministerium wir lassen uns
unsere Erfolge jedenfalls nicht klein
reden Robert Habeck hat zum Beispiel
gerade ein Preis gewonnen den begehrten
energieküste Award eine Gesellschaft aus
Schleswig-Holstein deren Aufgabe die
Umsetzung jener Energiewende ist
überreichte den Preis konkret ihr
Geschäftsführer Hinrich Habeck Roberts
Bruder
ja meine Fresse Buhu es war ein
symbolischer Preis niemand Bereich hat
sich hier ja und wenn ich allein höre
was uns die CSU jetzt entgegen kotzt
Mafia Clan Vergleiche wohlgemerkt von
den Amigos die das Ehefrauen einstellen
erfunden haben
meine Mutter überreicht mir den
bester Sohn ich bin zwar Einzelkind aber
trotzdem sehr stolz
auch mama du bist ja verrückt Christian
Ehring vielen Dank danke schön
[Applaus]
Christian Ehring so also komm
immerhin für den trauzeugenjob in der
Energieagentur wird jetzt das
Bewerbungsverfahren wiederholt besser
ist das und was bisher geschah gibt
sogar bald als Fernsehserie
Katana greifen eine junge Frau am Anfang
ihrer Karriere gegen alle Widerstände
folgt sie ihrem großen Traum sie wird
eines Tages mal irgendwas mit Klima
machen ja schade kann man nichts machen
oder wie nur mit Abitur
bis zu diesem einen Bewerbungsgespräch
das alles ändern und dann sehe ich sie
haben Puppenspiel auf Bachelor studiert
aber abgebrochen ja das war jetzt
einfach nicht so meins ich sehe mich da
eher schon im Klimabereich wissen Sie
was
sie haben den Job
und danke Papa das Vergessen
und die andere Bewerberin die war wohl
echt scheiße
die neue Doku-Soap bei RTL2 die
gleichens eine einzelne Familie teilt
sich alle wichtigen Stellen
ja klar ich leite die Abteilung für
Mobilität und Verkehr zusammen mit Onkel
Wolfgang
[Musik]
denn ein reichen kommt selten allein
oder endet katjanas Traum bevor er
begonnen hat denn sie hat einen neuen
Chef es ist ihr eigener Sohn und er hat
sie auf den Kicker
Mama hat den Quartalsbericht den du
haben wolltest
und dann taucht doch noch ihre seit
Jahren verschollene böse
Zwillingsschwester wieder auf
[Musik]
Jessica auch hier
das alles diese Woche bei die gleichens
eine schrecklich Verwandte Familie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es wird ihnen nicht entgangen sein dann
war ja diese Woche auch noch Tag der
Arbeit diesmal allerdings ganz ohne die
gefürchteten mai Krawalle was ja auch
kein Wunder ich meine wer schmeißt noch
Molotow Cocktails bei den Benzinpreisen
allerdings ist der Inflationstreiber
Nummer eins inzwischen unser Essen ja
Lebensmittel insgesamt liegt die
Inflationsrate bei rund 7 Prozent bei
Lebensmitteln sind es 22%. auch deshalb
ist es total richtig dass wir über einen
Erhöhung des Mindestlohns diskutieren
immer mehr Menschen brauchen hier sogar
einen Zweitjob um über die Runden zu
kommen so wie dieser ungelernte
aushilfsbusfahrer hier der
wahrscheinlich zum ersten Mal im Leben
Spaß bei der Arbeit hat
im Rahmen seiner Möglichkeiten natürlich
der Fahrzeugführung bestellt der kriegt
sie auch der Anteil der Lebensmittel an
der Gesamtinflation beträgt 40% so und
jetzt wird spannend meine Damen und
Herren laut einer aktuellen Studie lässt
sich ein Drittel dieser Preiserhöhung
nicht durch Hersteller Kosten erklären
spielt hier etwa der Faktor Gier eine
Rolle
[Musik]
ja nur als Arbeitshypothese von
verdeckten Preiserhöhungen durch
verpackungstricks mal ganz zu schweigen
ich sage nur Rama Rama ist ein gutes
Beispiel früher 500 Gramm jetzt 400 in
derselben Verpackung frisch
ausgezeichnet als Mogelpackung des
Jahres der Hersteller erklärt uns
gegenüber eine verpackungsänderung hätte
zusätzliche Kosten verursacht die wir
nicht an die Konsumentinnen und
Konsumenten weitergeben wollten
das sind Engel in Menschengestalt meine
Damen und Herren beziehungsweise
Margarine Gestalt selbstverständlich
wirken sich auch die gestiegenen
Erzeugerpreise auf den Endpreis aus
selbst popeliges Obst wird plötzlich zum
Luxus das stimmt schon so
was aber vor allem fehlt ist Transparenz
wie genau kommen Preise zustande meine
wir kennen den Erzeuger und den
Verbraucherpreis was dazwischen passiert
ist ist eine Blackbox will man uns
partout nicht verraten wahrscheinlich
läuft es bei den großen Supermarktketten
so da sitzen hoch qualifizierte Experten
diskutieren alle möglichen
marktparameter die Gewinnmargen und dann
fällt halt irgendwann die Entscheidung
ne hier z.B wird der Kaffee 18 % teurer
ja wenn ihr das unfair findet ihr eure
Preise festlegt ne wollen sie aber nicht
stattdessen liefern sich die Ketten
gerade einen Krieg mit den Hersteller
Edeka boykottiert die Produkte von 17
großen Marken weil die bei ihren
Preisforderungen zu gierig sein darunter
Global Player wie Unilever oder Mars ne
ja wir erleben quasi
der Leben quasi die Meuterei gegen das
Bounty
laut edeka-chef sieht man sich als Zitat
Anwalt der Verbraucher die auf facebook
stellt der explizit Pepsi an den Pranger
Pepsi hat sich dazu entschieden uns
nicht mehr zu beliefern weil wir gegen
ungerechtfertigt hohe Preise sind
probiert doch mal unsere Alternativen
Moment sie ist doch schon die
Alternative oder
[Musik]
ist egal stattdessen vertickt Edeka mehr
eigene Hausmarken was super praktisch
ist weil man da viel mehr Druck auf
seine Zulieferer machen kann fragen Sie
mal deutsche Bauern wie das läuft kurz
gesagt bei diesem Thema gibt es die
guten leider gar nicht
tatsächlich fahren die Lebensmittel
Giganten wie nestleder none oder
Unilever zur Zeit riesige Gewinne ein
aber auch die vier deutschen
supermarktkonzerne Edeka Rewe Lidl und
Aldi haben wohl nie größere Gewinne
gemacht
was soll das heißen die machen das nur
wegen Geld ja nestlé hat im ersten
Quartal weniger Lebensmittel verkauft
aber mehr Umsatz gemacht verstehen sie
hohe Preise gute Besserung und natürlich
treibt auch die Marktmacht der großen 4
Rewe Edeka Aldi und Lidl seit Jahren bei
uns die Preise hoch die haben seit 2005
mehr als ein Dutzend Mitbewerber
übernommen weil sie kein deutsches
kartellam daran gehindert hat und
kontrollieren jetzt 85% des Marktes da
braucht es auch gar keine
Preisabsprachen die beobachten Sie
einfach den ganzen Tag gegenseitig
derweil hat man in Spanien die
Mehrwertsteuer auf Grundnahrungsmittel
gesenkt Inflationsrate bei den Spaniern
3,8%. ja in Schweden und Frankreich gibt
es Anti inflationsprogramme auch für den
Lebensmittelbereich man könnte sagen ja
man könnte sagen mehr Druck von oben auf
die Händler und was macht unsere
Regierung
Handyvideos und selbstverständlich sind
alle unsere Bemühungen darauf gerichtet
dass die Inflation Stück für Stück
wieder zurückgeht ein bisschen kann man
das schon sehen so richtig im
Portemonnaie spüren wird man das
allerdings wohl erst im Laufe des
nächsten Jahres ja nur supi dann
verschieben Sie die Anschaffung von
sagen wir mal Graubrot doch einfach ins
nächste Jahr meine Damen und Herren ne
andererseits was soll die Politik auch
machen an der Markt macht der großen 4
ändern wir ja eh nichts mehr mit denen
legt sich keiner an
nach dem Erfolg von vorblogs kommt es
jetzt noch Gnadenloser noch härter mit
noch fetteren Karren vor Shops sie
kontrollieren 85% des Marktes das
bedeutet sie sagen an wie teuer der
Lauch ist du Lauch Spargel für 12 Euro
eat this motherfucker 3 Euro für
verdammten Blumenkohl und wenn du
deswegen blöd glotzt kostet er halt 4
kannst du ein Bioladen Einkaufen ach nee
der ist ja noch teurer und falls du auf
die Sau dumme Idee kommst das Kartellamt
einzuschalten hallo kartelland heißt es
bei uns ganz schnell noch so ein Spruch
möhrenbruch
die härtesten dealer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir kriegen ja bald eine schärfere Stadt
Hellweg mal gucken ob man es merkt so in
den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
beginnt jetzt schon die Neuauflage von
Trump gegen beiden der Rückkampf der
gerontosaurier
anderthalb Jahre vor der Wahl kurz hat
man sich über die doofen Amis da geht's
bei uns auch los zwei Jahre vor der
Bundestagswahl wer geht für die Union
ins Rennen bis neulich mindestens ein
Dreikampf doch seit dieser Woche ist
Markus Söder angeblich raus die Folge
wilde Spekulationen auf allen Kanälen
über die karfrage irgendwer mit Medien
macht mit
irgendwer mit Medien mit Friedrich
Küppersbusch
dicker Klopper diese Woche bei Markus
und Markus wenn man sehr genau hinhört
könnte man den Eindruck bekommen für
Söder habe sich da was erledigt für mich
ist das Thema erledigt das ist total
erledigt einmal werden nie wieder
antreten als Kanzlerkandidat für mich
ist die Sache erledigt für mich ist die
Sache erledigt aus dem syrischen ins
Hochdeutsche übersetzt wenn ich im
Herbst meine Bayern Wahl gewinne dann
müsst ihr in Berlin die Türen breiter
machen damit nicht nur ich durchpasse
sondern auch meine stattlichen Hoden bis
dahin allerdings fragen sich jetzt alle
ja also wer denn jetzt Friedrich Merz
oder wer sonst wird er als
Kanzlerkandidat antreten wer sie ich ja
da hat aber einer sein Luigi gelesen
unser Hendrik josefst für den Namen kann
da nichts unterschreibt aber gerne mit
höchstgrößt und endlich verhält es sich
mit seinem Geburtsort Rede in
Münsterland reden völlig unmöglich in
Rede im Münsterland ist er geboren
einfach jung genug für alles mögliche in
der Freizeit fährt wüst gerne Rad schon
auf Instagram zeigt er sich ganz privat
na halt Information gehen wir das lieber
alles noch mal im Einzelnen durch also
Fahrrad wenn Münsterländer auf die Welt
kommt klingelt's Verantwortung zu
übernehmen das treibt mich seit meiner
frühesten Jugend an das ist immer ganz
gut ein bisschen Münsterländer
Fahrradfahren in Düsseldorfer Büro ich
werde mir für die Menschen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen Bein ausreißen okay
und da dann halt E-Bike sein zweites
Thema ist politisches Lebensmotto mehr
Kinderwagen schon zum amtsantrittsschub
wüst den Kinderwagen seiner kleinen
Tochter in den Landtag ja in
Wirklichkeit waren da natürlich die
Grünen drin also ein absolute
Medienprofi der über 40.000 € für Fotos
ausgibt wo Marco Söder einfach durch
eine Radarfalle Hämmern würde von
Politik hält sich der Schlag sie in
nordwestfalle gekonnt fern nutzerrat das
waren die verspielten grünen der
komplette Verkehrsinfarkt in NRW ja das
liegt am früheren Verkehrsminister der
hieß zwar natürlich Hendrik wüst aber
wie man bei uns sagt die älteren
PassantInnen sind begeistert schick
Achtung vor allen Dingen erstmal
nicht so
ja leider schon vergeben bei offiziellen
Anlässen zeigt wüst zwar seine Gattin
vor seht her die Wüste lebt aber in
Wirklichkeit läuft da was in Bayern
Liebe Hendrik ich glaube wir haben immer
eine sehr gute Zusammenarbeit gehabt
über all die Jahre wir waren immer im
sms-drat wir waren im gesprächsrat
Markus Söder rollt jedes Mal den roten
Rettich aus wenn Sie ein ratiger Kumpel
aus Düsseldorf vorbeischauen seit vielen
Jahren Coach der bayerische Häuptling
seinen Schützling im zweckfreien
rumgestikulieren und da staunen viele
Söder und Laschet hatten sich doch
zerlegt bis die Union die Wahl vergeigt
hat also wieso streichelt und
schmeichelt so der jetzt im neuen aus
Düsseldorf über allen politischen
Erfolgen von Hendrik an ihm kannst nicht
liegen der Mann ohne Eigenschaften hat
für Söder vor allem einen Vorteil
Hendrik wüst lieb haben ist die
eleganteste Art Friedrich Merz in den
Arsch zu treten
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an und
abonniert den Kanal danke
oh nein eine Zeitschleife habt ihr etwa
nicht den Kanal abonniert Hilfe sofort
draufklicken oder ich bin hier für immer
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an